he has sold more than 40 million records
worldwide
won the grammy award for best male rock
vocal performance
a record four times in a row think about
that for a second
the superstar rocker that's the cover of
his book is now the author of a new
memoir let
love rule it takes readers on the
journey from his birth to the release of
his debut album in 1989
it's also called by the way let love
rule lenny kravitz joins us this morning
from the bahamas hi lenny kravitz
it's good to see you good morning good
morning are you going to watch me see
you
i never asked you for anything lenny are
you going to wear your sunglasses the
whole time
i'm just asking i got to tell you i just
i just woke up this is early but it's a
beautiful
i went to bed about four hours ago i was
in the studio all night all right you
can do whatever you want lenny kravitz
but listen
journey is a word for you in the book
you're called master leonard
lenny ellie nnie eddie and romeo blue
did you struggle was it a struggle for
you to find yourself and all those names
have meaning to you by the way people
will have to
read the book to get it but did you
struggle to find yourself
it was a journey but it was a beautiful
journey and uh
the fact that i had all of these
backgrounds you know
uh growing up uh with a russian jewish
father
and a christian african-american
caribbean mother living in manhattan
in bed-stuy brooklyn uh in new york city
in los angeles in the bahamas it was a
very very colorful and uh
rich childhood which really was provided
me with this playground where i could uh
experience and learn all sorts of things
i know your mom we should say was roxy
roker on the
on the jeffersons um and your dad
your dad you and your dad had a very
complicated relationship and you
ultimately say in the book as
complicated as it was it was a
pivotal part of your journey talk about
your mom and your dad and what
they both brought to your life your mom
was such a classy classy lady lenny who
adored you
and you her
thank you yeah she was a very beautiful
honest fair person
uh full of so much love and my father
was full of love too but he just had a
hard
time showing it to me
maybe in certain ways but he showed it
in other ways and he
uh he challenged me yeah uh
which was which was good i i needed
him in my life uh
to give me that that certain rub
and uh put that uh heat under me
uh which prompted me to uh
you know leave the house early yeah
lenny
i love how you say leave the house early
that was quite a confrontation because
you wanted to go to a concert
i think was buddy rich he said no you're
not going and as a teenager you said yes
i am
and you guys got nose to nose and he
said if you leave
you're not coming back and you left not
even knowing where you were going to go
it wasn't just you left the house early
okay yeah okay yeah
um i i i really wanted to go see buddy
rich that night you know i wanted to
check out his technique
and uh you know such a great drummer and
so i asked my father or i guess i kind
of told him
no i asked him uh can i go and he said
no
and i said but i really need to see
buddy rich you know we don't know how
many times we're gonna get to see him
uh he said you went out last night and i
asked him what that had to do with
tonight anyway it got to the point where
we were nose-to-nose it was the first
time i stood up to him
yeah uh which i think amazed the both of
us
um because you know my father was a
you know a green beret yeah military guy
he was a tough guy
yeah but uh i stood up to him and he
said you know
if you go you can't come back because
you have to
you know and you said i'm gonna have to
work under the rules of this house which
which
which i understand and and and respect
so i grabbed the duffel bag and packed
my few things and i
went to the buddy rich concert and after
the show i had no idea where i was going
to live but i
began to find my way that night
it's anthony mason i wanted i wanted to
talk about one of the stories that i
that i found
particularly pointed in the book and you
you talk about wanting to wear
a yarmulke when you were growing up but
then learning
that if you have an afro you you can't
really wear a yarmulke
but it seemed that that that sort of
thing
it seemed to sort of symbolize the whole
dilemma you dealt with right 70s
yeah it well it was the 70s and i had an
afro
uh you know and uh it was hard for
uh that to stay on but uh
yeah of course i i i grew up i grew up
going to
church and going to temple and uh you
know i got to experience
uh the joy of both sides you know i
the other chapter i really like was
about you and lisa bonnet
that what you two had lenny i thought
was so magical
the story that you told about the first
kiss honest to god had me swooning i
just thought wow
people live their whole lives and they
don't get anything like that but it was
magical she of course is now happily
married to jason mamoy you ultimately
you two got a divorce but she had a huge
influence on your life
absolutely absolutely you know
everything i experienced uh
were all jewels that i picked up along
the way yeah
and uh when when we met
uh i think we really saw
uh each other you know when i looked at
her
and when i looked within her i saw
myself
and had a had a greater understanding of
myself at that time
uh because she was so confident and so
free so artistic uh
and smart and you know really in touch
um ahead of her time
yeah and as as were you at that time
that was for you and at that time the
portal opened
and everything that i was searching for
artistically
uh came came through me
um effortlessly at that point you know i
had been searching for my sound
searching for my voice
and when we got together
and and and created this world that we
were living in
everything just came out naturally and i
didn't have to search anymore
i'm wondering lenny because we have to
go if you feel
as cool as you look i just got a text
from my friend adrian i'ma call her out
she says
lenny kravitz is a fine ass man oh my
god
so i'm wondering do you feel as cool as
you look and does your favorite daughter
zoe think that you're cool
um if if you call zoey and ask her about
my character she will say that
i am one of the group one of the
goofiest people i don't
that she knows so uh don't don't let the
cool facade fool you
well i'm fooled i'm fooled and i liked
it lenny kravitz i thought the best line
i loved how the book ended
number one you talk about all your
musical influences james brown jackson
five earth wind and fire
but your last line of the book is to be
continued
and may that be so please continue to
soar i can't wait to see you again thank
you so much
for getting up early the name of the
book is called thank you for your time
thank you for your time and have a
wonderful day okay lenny kravitz
always good to see you the name of the
book is called let love rule it goes on
sale tomorrow wherever you like to buy
your books